yeah watching to get another video just
one guitar played him before okay let's
play play regular Kings Indian set up
you with the Queen a five and don't
really know the details but it's an old
favorite of some former team mates of
mine so it's not so great but it's a way
to play without them knowing so many
concrete lines
I kept cream of that if you place d 5 I
take it need to cherish the rare moment
where I actually have extra time on the
clock
hmm yeah well be five don't really play
be five in such a position but what do I
play actually you know cam yeah he's
somehow not playing d5 this is this is a
bit irritating habit he can go d5 now
yeah it's not I'm Kevlar I don't really
like this it's good before coming before
and maybe c5
you before Quincy 7i it's not a great
position really not yeah it's um it's a
good idea for white to not play d5 so
quickly not that it's bad playing a
quick t5 before it's not bad but this is
just just a bit more more problematic
black just suffers from the spacer
disadvantage and it's hard to say how to
get counterplay maybe this one going to
see five possible
hmm ok I will hear he went for the keep
it simple approach but this this
position is some it's not so terrible
like
should be able to to hold this it's not
easy to do to get anything active going
though this is clear maybe I can first I
need to get rid of the stuff here they
can take with the Queen actually okay so
get rid of the rooks you know what one
plan is 97 f 86 d for some typical plan
white can try Bishop to h3 so some good
idea
yeah there's still not not happening
much so it's still still rather on
rather even I think okay this Bishop c8
stuff is some is of course slightly
annoying but what can you do
maybe I should have gone Queen the edge
in before
she tried to go to g4 not sure if it is
dangerous but but I better prevented
he's got a bat knight on c3 does this
piece is the one he needs to I'm try to
improve 25 I've got Bishop f6 ok so now
my diaz to go bishop age 61 tried
something similar what he is doing
attacking the apron but I've got the
King here now protecting this yeah
so this is a good square yeah if you
take now I've got B 2 B 2 is my next my
next square I didn't want to take and
play Bishop g7 because it's got a five
now I can just go back and try to to get
there again yep I have King e7 though oh
wait wait wait wait just just a moment
Knight f6 me damn still so playlist
the problem is I'm not really
threatening anything on be should be
should be too i mean this is just a nice
square it's not like winning okay let's
let's start let's do it I can I can
protect it should be to maybe a five
next if he goes we should be seven yeah
should I take it now if he takes Nigeria
okay I'm king of six I cannot play f
king f7 though okay let's let's go here
hmm
night-night they're interesting
check
oh yes this was check here really maybe
how maybe he can do that the edge part
is it's not bad at all
I didn't really didn't really appreciate
the h-bomb it is strong
or before before they can take c6
I can I can need to need to use the
night
time warning
no okay get some end game with with
nothing on the board yeah yeah no no way
to to to anything I'm not sure probably
it is it is a draw but I thought really
here this could be something but maybe
maybe it isn't Kimmy 7am bishop here
yeah maybe this was too too passive
really computers play a 585 takes Bishop
e3 the systems may be real really a
really better and this is probably too
passive yeah still have half chances may
be king d8 now yeah okay it's difficult
to to play this this perfectly idea even
though even a slight trouble the H bonus
is is a problem yeah very tricky game
thanks for watching